[Music]
you know you're listening to right now
it's called to base hit it's by the Jazz
at Lincoln Center orchestra with Wynton
Marsalis featuring Jon batiste the song
is on the new album music of John Lewis
which is a tribute to the late jazz
composer and pianist Lewis was a mentor
to Marsalis the album's executive
producer Charlie asked him about his
contemporaries back in 1984 weten
Marsalis are we slowly beginning to
appreciate jazz musicians because I mean
most people would say that we have not
recognized the genius of jazz musician
primarily because 90% of the more black
write and I don't really think that we
even approaching recognizing it know I'd
have to answer truthfully I don't think
so
yes thank goodness how did John ran us
both out of here I don't know we're
surprising your mustache or Charlie our
guest this morning of doing their part
to highlight the jazz foul of the past
and future trumpeter Wynton Marsalis is
and managing an artistic director of
Jazz at Lincoln Center Jon batiste is a
pianist composer and bandleader the Late
Show with Stephen Colbert good morning
long the number one Late Show TV
contrasty lot of hard work a team thank
you very mad interview was 1984 yes it
changes oh yeah
a lot has changed since then first we
change them yeah but I mean a lot has
changed you know it's been a lot of
change in the scene a lot more younger
musicians for us with much more music
available and what made the change I
just I just think the momentum of the
music a lot of what we've done a jazz
Lincoln Center has helped obviously with
the music we still tour around the world
and we could collaborate with a lot of
musicians but they're also the music is
difficult to play so there's always a
lot of younger musicians who want to
play it which is what John represents
and what he's represented on this album
is the quality of playing has has gone
up for younger musicians about the
collaboration John cuz you
known wenton since you were a young boy
you said yeah I was I was over you
13 or 13 years old we actually would
play basketball before we started
playing music together he had a nice G
but yeah a nice jump shot yeah true
funny left-handed it's always catch you
but you know the music I feel is about
bridging the gap between the generations
it's about sharing and breaking barriers
that may be color barriers maybe racial
barriers all maybe something about you
know the older generation feels like
what y'all doing is not happening the
young generation is like what y'all
doing this past day that's all we all
need that when actually jazz is not like
that all yeah so did he reach out to you
and say let's work together what
happened well he called and when you get
a 30-year veteran from Kenner Louisiana
call you up and this was in 2013 uh-huh
to do the music of John Lewis one of the
most venerable the highest level
jazz come oppose a piano player I had to
say yes here's the kind of thing which
it's a challenge it's an autistic Mount
Everest to climb no no I love this
that's what you said in the liner notes
as artistic Mount Everest I think that's
very powerful how did you know he could
do it
yeah well I've known them since he was
13 or 14 it's not a lot of younger
musicians you know the the best of them
and most serious of them rides and I
mean I've known him so it's almost like
we're in the same family Leslie was
taught my grandparents yeah my father
would be like a grandparent to John my
mother taught all of us me taught Harry
Connick he taught all of us in that
generation then even later generation
with John so the second he start playing
first I get a call from my father's he
heard no panties can play Alice so you
know we've been knowing oh he we have a
generational relationship and then even
more than the New Orleans connection he
came to Juilliard he's in New York and
all the musicians are always talking
about the young musicians and who can
play and I have a lot of experience also
playing with him to talk with him in my
house many times yeah well more like
family band going to Juilliard is an
interesting thing because so many jazz
artists are really very good musicians
with a very sophisticated knowledge oh
yeah easy but you have to be John Lewis
did an example for all of
says erudite as he was and as serious as
he was about music and the quality of
his playing I knew John would be up to
the intellectual study understand who
mr. Lewis was and then most importantly
coming to the bandstand because when you
get on Vance that he could be very
nerve-wracking he was also the music
direct like he took care of all the
people he announced everything he was so
fantastic everyone your band was like
man my man is for real I know how
involved you are in arts education and
you've been awarded the National Medal
of Arts by the National Endowment for
the Arts in this new budget that the
current president is proposing there
will be a cut in that funding for the
Arts what would be the outcome of a cut
in those I mean it there's so much wrong
with so much that's going on and our
politics not just directed at him we
swing it back and forth like a ship
listing in the ocean your national
budget is symbolic so you basically tell
in the world this is what we as a nation
think about our arts which is our
collective memory our wisdom we don't
know whenever fascists or people who and
I'm not saying he's a fascist like I'm
part of any that kind of bashing and
ridiculous there's a reality to things
when we tell people our arts are not
important our wisdom is not important
we're preparing our public to be more
ignorant so that we can exploit them
more and we're going to realize that
white and black people are certain
economic levels a certain level of
exploitation is taking place as
intellectuals so you don't want to
disconnect yourself from your
intellectual tradition in any way it's
painful to see it not just that many
things but J is painful in his ignorant
everybody say if you want to know what
the values are of a country look at its
budget yes it's ignorant we don't want
to be viewed in the world that way yeah
mmm so wonderful to have very well sugar
yeah what Marsellus muhammad EES
continued success thank you